[Music]
Star Wars is getting weirder by the
minute and now it seems the Jedi have
got zombies to contend with so how does
that work
spoilers for Ahsoka episode 4 ahead
apparently Ahsoka likes to have a set
amount of villains on retainer since
Morgan ellsbeth's plan to use the eye of
Scion in order to bring back grand
admiral thrawn has now reached
hyperspace the chis chess master will
likely return sooner rather than later
with Morgan balen skull shinhati and
former Inquisitor morocc still firmly in
the mix it seems that the show runs the
risk of suffering a surplus of
antagonists that is right up until the
socatano faces Moroccan a forest
lightsaber duel having already clashed
with Ahsoka on corellia morocc enters
the fight with the kind of confidence
that suggests he's quite unfamiliar with
the sokus history with double blade
lightsaber wielders indeed the Jedi
Outcast has a track record of defeating
opponents like this almost with cheat
code level ease and when morocc tries to
come at her with his lightsaber spin
function he finds this out the hard way
morocc's demise could be ahsoka's most
absurdly overpowered Victory yet when
the former Inquisitor attacks her she
cuts him down with a single lightsaber
strike this even causes morocc to
explode into Dusty smoke as if he got
his franchises mixed up and walked into
an Avengers movie it's a freaky moment
that may or may not be explained later
on but we already have a decent idea of
what may have caused morocc's dramatic
transformation into green Mist it's
entirely possible that morocc was Undead
all along and that he was only walking
around because of a creepy night sister
spell called the chant of Resurrection
Morgan ellsbeth seemed like your average
Imperial mini boss type when she first
appeared in the Mandalorian season 2 but
the illusion didn't last long not only
did she have important information
pertaining to thrawn's possible location
but she wasn't afraid to grab a baskar
spear and face Ahsoka in an intense
one-on-one duel Ahsoka goes on to reveal
that Morgan is a night sister of
dathomir which is essentially a witch
who can harness the force as dark magic
as it turns out Morgan plans to rebuild
the Empire with thrawn as its ruler the
villain's night sister Heritage could
explain several unanswered questions
about morocc's place in the grand scheme
of things it seems clear that Morgan is
pretty strong as far as night's sister
years ago and she could very well be
powerful enough to use their high-end
spells like the chant of Resurrection
this spell effectively reanimates the
dead into zombie-like figures and
manifests as you guessed it Eerie green
mist
witchcraft
aside from explaining morocc's minimal
dialogue in the whole Green Smoke thing
his Undead nature would also explain why
an ex-inquisitor sits further down the
pecking order than balon's Apprentice
Shin who would take orders from a
magically created zombie no matter how
impressive his villain credentials may
be if Morgan indeed animated morocc with
the chant of resurrection of course he
probably would have found himself in
trouble even if he had managed to beat
Ahsoka in the duel unlike your average
zombie the Star Wars Undead suffer very
concrete expiration dates which tend to
depend on the night sister who performs
the reanimation spell should Morgan die
or simply stop maintaining the spell the
undead morocc would have fallen
instantly Morgan obviously survives the
episode but her departure from the
Galaxy at the end of the episode
probably would have spelled the end for
morocc and okay sure we've seen Moroccan
Morgan operate on different planets so
Morgan's chant of Resurrection has an
impressive range still it must be tied
to the person who cast the spell and
Morgan leaving the entire galaxy behind
in her search for thrawn would probably
push the chance limits pretty hard even
if it didn't a miserable life is a
mist-powered force zombie doesn't really
sound like a sweet gig in that sense
Ahsoka episode 4 probably gave morocc
the best ending he could hope for
foreign